E
SERIES, WE KNEW WE JUST NEEDED
TO PLAY.
RO: LUKA, 46, 14 ASSISTS.
KAWHI AND PG, 50 POINTS AND 19
ASSISTS.
HERE IS LUKA IN THE LOSING
EFFORT.
>> PERSONNEL WISE OR SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO GO INTO NEXT
SEASON.
>> THAT IS A QUESTION THAT YOU
SHOULD ASK THE GUY THAT MAKES
THE TEAM.
I AM JUST A PLAYER.
I THINK WE PLAYED GREAT.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF THIS TEAM.
OBVIOUSLY, I HATE LOSING.
I AM PROUD OF MY TEAM.
>> NOW THAT YOU HAVE HAD A
SECOND RUN THROUGH THE NBA
PLAYOFFS, WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED
ABOUT PLAYING IN THIS LEAGUE AT
THIS TIME OF YEAR?
>> I MEAN, THERE IS ALWAYS --
YOU LEARN DIFFERENT STUFF BUT
JUST IT'S DIFFERENT IN THE
REGULAR SEASON AND GAME SEVEN IS
TOUGH.
YOU GOT TO GIVE EVERYTHING.
WE WILL COME BACK NEXT YEAR.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
>> YOU CARE ABOUT WINNING, NOT
NUMBERS, BUT THE NUMBERS YOU PUT
UP IN THIS SERIES WERE
RIDICULOUS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO IN THIS SERIES AND
EVEN LAST YEAR AS WELL?
>> I MEAN, NOTHING YET.
WE WERE IN THE PLAYOFFS TWICE.
WE LOST BOTH TIMES SO NOTHING
YET.
WE GET PAID TO WIN AND WE DID
NOT DO IT.
>> BRETT TOWNSEND.
>> DALLAS MORNING NEWS.
LAST YEAR AGAINST THE CLIPPERS,
YOU GUYS NEVER LED IN THE
SERIES.
HIS TIME, YOU WERE UP 2-0, HAVE
THREE GAMES AT HOME.
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL LOOK BACK
AT THE SERIES AS ONE THAT GOT
AWAY?
>> EVERY SERIES YOU LOSE, YOU'RE
GOING TO THINK LIKE THAT.
WHAT COULD WE DO BETTER?
WHICH GAMES WE WOULD WIN, BUT
THAT IS IN THE PAST.
WE HAVE TO LOOK FORWARD IN THE
NEXT SEASON AND GET THE MISTAKES
OUT.
>> SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NEWSGROUP.
I WAS WONDERING, TRYING TO
EXCHANGE JERSEYS WITH YOU.
AS A FOLLOW-UP, WHAT DOES IT
MEAN TO YOU?
YOU PLAYED A LONGER SERIES THIS
TIME, BUT TO LOSE TO THE SAME
TEAM AND BACK TO BACK YEARS?
>> THE FIRST ONE, WE DID IN THE
LOCKER ROOM.
THE SECOND ONE, YOU KNOW, IT'S
TOUGH.
IT'S THE SAME RIFLE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LOSE AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO COME BACK NEXT YEAR
AND LOOK AT THESE PLAYOFFS AND
SEE WHAT WE DID WRONG AND JUST
KEEP GOING FROM THERE.
>> TWO AND SPANISH NOW.
PEDRO.
-- IN SPANISH NOW.
PICKREL.
-- PEDRO.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> MET -- LAST IS THERE
MORE.
>> -- IS ERIC MOORE.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> ISIAH: -- >> [SPEAKING
SPANISH]
RO: HERE IS ANOTHER FACTOR.
THE 77 POINTS CREATED BY LUKA
DONCIC SCORING OR ASSISTING, THE
MOST EVER BY A PLAYER IN A GAME
SEVEN ACCORDING TO TIM MCMAHON.
I BELIEVE THEY CALL HIM BEN
MCMAHON IS WHAT THEY CALL HIM.